today's class is learned from the
legends and because I've always been
frustrated by how few examples are are
great women chess players in history I
wanted to bring up Vera men chick who
was the first woman in history to
compete on equal terms with the top men
of her day now she didn't win as many
games as she lost against the very top
guys but she did win some and it
irritated the men she was playing so
much that they started something called
the very mention club which was a club
that you absolutely didn't want to be a
member of it would mean that you had
lost to her so that kind of gives you a
sense of the sexism unfortunately she
died way too young and she didn't get a
chance to like really show her full
potential she died only at in 1944 so
she died in World War two actually in
the London Blitz so pretty sad and I
think she was she was pretty young at
the time and she'd won a bunch of World
Chess Championships she was in her 30s
yeah so anyway we're gonna look at some
of her games wish there were a lot more
but of course she was succeeded by many
great female chess champions notably
judit polgár who recently retired and
actually did compete among the best men
of her time with the with great success
even becoming the top 10 players in the
world and now we see that how you find
who i should have lost from the other
day in my endgame class but she is also
doing excellently and really taking up
really Judith's role of competing with
the top players in the world so this is
a game that very mentok was playing
against her really remain female rival
and in a way she didn't really have any
female rivals because she was a lot
better than most of the women at that
time but the closest one was a
fascinating woman called Sonia graph who
I write about a little bit
I first book chest [ __ ] Sonya graph it
was this incredible person I mean her
chest was good but really she was a
writer she was a bottom vivant she
protested against the Nazis ended up
moving to Buenos Aires where she was in
a chess tournament because World War two
broke out at that exact time so and if
she had gone back to Germany she would
have perhaps been in some trouble so
really a fascinating personality and in
this game she is playing against
veramente kin a women's world
championship match and she won this
particular game so one of the few games
she got the better of era plaque to move
men jake has just made this move Bishop
to a 6 which turns out to be an error
can anybody tell me why ok so I've
started with my takes f3 and now they
can't take back with a queen because of
what right so instead they have to take
back with a pond and after G takes f3
what can black do exactly Bishop takes
each to check and then after King takes
h2 exactly so this is a very important
forcing variation in which now black
ends up winning back that Bishop 186 and
ends up up up on right so let's take a
quick look at that on the demo board for
anybody who didn't take a look Bishop
Knight takes have to read queen takes up
three years hangs this fish up right
where as if you play pawn takes up three
now this trip takes H to check king
cakes h2 allows this nice double attack
queen to d6 check and now when the King
moves away we get this Bishop here and
the best thing of all is that we've also
stripped the king of some defense right
so this is going to be quite a good
position for right I mean for back so
that is an example of one one tough game
there by Vera but there is a really
beautiful game
am probably her most famous game that
you want again Sonia graph which I'm now
going to show you okay so we're just
going to go over this game from the
beginning so it started out with c4 e6
yeah I like that 93 D 5 D for but it's
not really the English anymore is it and
now it's just transposed exactly you
guys make a good team are you related or
something d4 Knight f6 and now night of
three night bd7 how many people in this
room play like Queen pawn openings like
d4c for how many people start the game
with 1.e4 okay yeah that's great me too
but it's still fun to look at these
openings and you'd be surprised at the
commonalities you know there's different
as you might think a lot of times you
get similar tactics in games especially
in lines where white ends up playing
before it's a moment and the position
opens off right because that's really
what characterizes ephors opposed to d4
and ce4 physicians tend to be a lot more
open do you know what an open position
means what's that mean right so how do
you clear a board and test
not capturing pieces as much it's more
about capturing something very specific
what clears the board for pieces and
Jess yeah exactly so open positions are
when you trade pawns when you trade off
pond's that creates open positions
castles castles what do you think black
did yes got it alright and now it's
White's turn what is white through here
I mean what does white do it should
white do
it's a couple possible moves here for
Wyatt but what are you saying what would
you guys do is why you here so um it
doesn't come as naturally to people who
don't really play d4 but there's a lot
of different plans yeah you can play b3
with the idea of Bishop b2 sure you
could play Bishop d2 what other moved
you sometimes wanna play in these types
of positions sometimes white wants to
strike forward with what would be for
right so that's what veramente did in
this game you did play e4 and then there
were a bunch of trades and now the
position has opened up pawn a pair of
pond has been traded so the position is
more open now and now black played a
very typical move in this position the
kind of instinctual move what do you
think black lady r my water
first thing I see at night of sex yeah
my desk is a really instinctual mover
baka play here and this is going to come
up a lot when you play native 6 it
really helps defend your cane right so
that's a good thing white played back
Bishop see two strong Bishop black
played c5 trying to you know get some
space and now after d take c5 she played
Queen a5 planning to play work d 8 and
recapture that pawn it's not easy to
keep it right because you can't play be
four you can just take it so white here
play Bishop e3 you're getting that and
how it is a pie pie instead you mean
instead of playing Bishop e3 here Yeah
right um ya know that seems like a
decent idea I wonder if maybe that
Bishop can come to a six at some moment
black you mean you mean black well
that's the question I think he's
thinking that it's actually harder now
but the problem is we could probably
play c5 anyway and then Bishop e7 so I'm
not really sure how much it helps you
unless you can like quickly come in with
90 95 but right now the Queen can
capture that so you have to prepare it
right so seems decent but not nothing
particularly special really yeah I mean
it's definitely something you should be
looking at I agree because you're going
to lose that pond anyway so why not
consider just pushing it forward instead
she plays Bishop e3 though and now black
babe you should take see if I
recapturing the pond and now white
played Bishop to d2
attacking the Queen so what's the point
of Bishop to e3 it just gets captured
and you have to move your vision twice
yeah basically to seem strange but she
is a good idea with that mom when she
plays Bishop to do to with tempo against
the Queen on a five where does she want
to go with the bishop next yeah why do
you think c3 might be strong exactly the
bishops are nicely aim down the Kings
side which we were going to see you
later is very very important yeah um
like in this position well I think she
was probably thinking that if she played
Bishop d2 right away maybe she was
thinking that now the Queen can take on
c5 and then after Bishop c3 she has to
worry about Queen takes e4 that's
probably why but that being said I mean
these games aren't completely perfect so
I don't think I'm sure like I'm sure you
know that's one of things about studying
in class a game the accuracy in them is
usually not going to be nearly at the
level of the game that we see now and
pack a chest feel so you're going to
find a lot more improvements and ideas
that could be superior and that's
actually one of the fun things about
seeing classic games that sometimes
there's not as much resistance offered
in them so you get to see more brilliant
attacks you know what I mean the Pat
players today are such great defenders
part of the reason the top players are
such great defenders today is a lot
anybody want to tell me why the top
players in the world are such fantastic
defenders exactly what side exactly
because they study with computers and
when you study with computers computers
are so good at defending you can't help
up learn a little bit of their tricks
and generally just have more confidence
like you study a position with a
computer and you see how miraculously
they defend and then if you're getting
attacked or like well maybe I could do
it to be my lucky day where
I think people used to be a little bit
more resigned to defeat now people are a
bit more resilient so good question but
you see what I'm saying that p mc5
bishops III maybe she was worried about
that so instead Bishop takes c5 Bishop
d2 Queen c7 and now Bishop t3 now let's
tell you a mover Bishop back the e72
guard this night so that the pawns won't
be doubled and now wait is indecent
moves here I mean what kind of things
might you consider in this position is
why there's not like one like obvious
move that seems to be better than all
other moves but just what are some
different things you might think about
Queen to d3 I like the idea the only
thing i don't like about queen bee three
like I see that you're just trying to
like what's just what's his tricky idea
with Queen day 3 Yeah right we're moving
the defender anybody want to explain how
we remove the defender here somebody who
maybe I was gonna try get removing the
defender what do we do got what do you
think kind of the idea what we can watch
what's an important defender in this
position in the back right that depends
upon an 87 so when we defend we take it
Queen takes eight seven so if we did
play Queen to d3 which is an excellent
suggestion I would certainly look at
that I'm always advocating looking for
forcing moves what would black do yeah
well II five we could play Bishop tasty
five and then take a night anyway ki six
is a possibility but I think there's a
little bit more of an active move you
can play the g6 doesn't move that we
replace we have to play it it's not like
a move we're excited about playing but
there is a move here that we're excited
about playing in in chess if you can
make a move that you're happy about and
also defend at the same time that's a
beautiful thing yeah yes work to da ting
is clean off the diagonal and when that
clean moves away this Bishop takes f6
won't have that same fret meanwhile we
also develop our rock so Queen d3 is not
the best move in my opinion what other
ideas are there merci one is an
interesting move seems a little bit
slower to me mmm right let's show that
let's show that so we're see one's a
little bit of a tricky idea he's hoping
that will take this pawn off yummy yummy
and then what will why do ok so Bishop
takes f6 and then after Bishop takes f6
what can I do that's right Bishop takes
eight seven check discovered attack on
the Queen so cheapo city here nut up but
really want is a useful no mercy Queenie
to seems like a supernatural mood to me
and that's actually what what veramente
played but another move that seems
really natural to me is 95 so yeah she
played cleaning to kind of just clearing
the Queen away because you know that
worth the eight might be coming up now
Sonya tried to develop her Bishop here
with v6 very logical
and metric jumped forward of 95 now
again she's threatening all the stuff
with Bishop f6 and night to H of it so
drop decided to stop it with the move g6
and now metric played Queen f3 so she's
hitting the work on a 8 as you can say
so Bishop to be seven and now why play
Queen age three so what's this right now
what's that what do you what do you want
to do is it takes one and then after
Bishop takes that's right Bishop takes
f6 and that after Bishop takes f6
there's what exactly so what would black
do here that's right so what should
black do a couple ways to defend here
okay yeah i think that ok so let's take
a look at all these suggestions we're
getting a lot of suggestions here we got
the suggestion h5 we got the suggestion
ephi we got the suggestion night h5 so
let's start with night h5 does anybody
see a good move here for a white hold
your horses because I think there's a
couple good moves here because I heard
you say you want to play d4 but g4 is
actually not that good of a move because
notice that this because that we don't
have to move this night we can actually
take this night instead right so that
might not be the best move so are there
any other really good moves here and not
yet yeah let them give us give them
another second hmm do this this kind of
motifs gonna come up later in the game
so it's very important so nine th five
white has a really nice move
five that you do I'll calling you first
I promise look I just want to let people
more people try to solve it your arms
getting tired oh oh you guys I don't you
feel sorry for him if you won't solve
this quickly his arms gonna fall off you
better get it fast oh no never mind he
is another arm he's okay he walked him
one who needs to want to give him a hand
you should give him a hand okay Queen
move you guys it's a hint is a queen
move it's not just any kind of Queen
move oh it's a very special thing those
a very very special Queen move anybody
see it yeah oh I said you'd say very
nice so Queen to h5 a beautiful move and
now after pawn takes age 5 what would
why do yes that's exactly right i hope
you're getting his voice in it in ya
visit dictate seven is checkmate this is
a very beautiful checkmate the bishops
are so powerful that's why I chess
players love having two bishops because
two bishops just wreak havoc under the
world like that the two bishops are the
most beautiful thing in chess so that's
why you can't play night eh I've but
thank you for you know demonstrating
that beautiful variation with your
defensive suggestion so the other two
defensive suggestions are the other two
depends and suggestions let's have a
vote on so to recap some people wanted
to play e5 which deals with the threat
by interfering with the bishop coming to
take xx and some people wanted to just
play h5
alright so how many people in this
position would play h5 to deal with the
threat raise your hand got a few people
how many people would actually play ePHI
all right okay in the game black played
age five so but you know both over
reasonable and both seem a bit dangerous
for black so it's kind of like either
way you're going to come under some fire
right so e5 now how would white try to
continue as a tack hair hurt her attack
see I mean even me well if everything
I've done i get i get the pronouns wrong
sometimes because there's so many more
men who play chess unfortunately you
mean it's good that so many men play
chess it's just that we wish there were
just as many women and girls who played
as well because then there'd be double
as many test fires uh yes i'm at four is
a pretty interesting idea it's a little
weakening though i might try i do like
that idea about four because you're I
see your immediate plan is that if i
take on f4 you can take on f6 and then
checkmate me just like we've been
looking at so yeah that's a really
interesting idea i would also think
about just targeting this pawn right
away with working one and it's like a
little bit tricky for them to you know
stop you from getting a good position
maybe work 81 so they can continue your
name again so I can continue Wilson's
idea if i play with a you on and that's
an excellent question by the way which
rock because normally you're absolutely
right like I would I would lean towards
playing look on FTE one because this
work might want to go to do you on but
in this particular situation I might
lean towards playing work AE 1 so that
next move I can play at four and this
work is still participating in the
attack right so this looks like it's
going to be really strong for white a
very promising attack instead though
Sonya graph played h5
and now there's a lot of interesting
possibilities for right so tell me what
you think take take a look and tell me
what you think you might do let's get
some suggestions yeah what do we were
you thinking up and trying to calculate
don't think it's best but look
interesting was a night tasty 6 ok so
the can knife a c6 sure what what
anything else people are looking at
night takes c6 I think it's a night such
a powerful piece and I feel like after
night s 6-6 Queenie 6 kh7 it seems like
we're hanging on like our defenses seem
a little bit better visit hd6 is a
really good try and there's actually
some fascinating variations you know
like suppose we play Bishop takes to g6
pawn takes g6 Queen takes c6 check and
then say they were to play King g7 the
only other option is king age 86 oh oh
ok I see we're saying but let's take a
look at this variation to after King to
g7 what moved his white hat here that
gives white perhaps a little bit of a
better end game
yeah Wilson yeah Queen takes up six is a
really interesting idea because after
Bishop takes at six what do we have not
a knife but afore gray 96 check and
white ends up up up just just a couple
pawns and black might end up winning one
of them back on c4 so it's not entirely
clear but certainly it looks like more
promising for Wyatt so if work takes we
can also play an ID 6 check because of
the pin right so that that seems fine
too that's right we still get the Queen
so that's one possibility but that isn't
what I romentic chose so I guess you
know she was looking more for keeping
the Queen's on the board and winning the
whole shebang air rather than
simplifying and that's always an
important question when you're attacking
because sometimes you reach a moment
where in your attack you can just
liquidate a bunch of stuff and get a
better end game yes or no um yes that's
why I that's why the the regular demo
board is over riddle because i always
like end up putting a piece on the wrong
sprayer uh-huh yeah question you had a
question ok so instead she actually just
plead this move work ad you on which is
actually extremely tricky and sneaky
well especially because of what happened
in the game you know the normal will
hear like when your opponent plays work
do you one you would normally I try to
contest the file even though the work
doesn't seem to have any anchors on in
the file still the kind of instinctual
response like the response that you
would play it up let's game is why if
your opponent plays work do you want you
play what you play worth the eight right
just kind of like um like he says hey I
say be right but instead she kind of got
tired I guess of some of the of the
things going on the side of the board
and decided to try to simplify and with
this move 94 what she's doing
is she is trying to attack here on g5
and set up some potential simplifying
tactics as well which we're going to see
in a second so this is where it gets
really interesting and wilson already
has an idea but i'm going to give you
guys another minute to kind of look at
this position and try to find the best
continuation so what do you what would
you do here is why so verra mentok this
is her most famous combination it's
featured in my book play like a girl
romentic she won the women's
championship seven times the World
Women's Championship to defend her title
successfully six times you can only
imagine if she didn't die in World War
two at such a young age how many times
she would have ended up winning the
women's world championship yeah she was
38 years old at the time of her death
all right well let's get started now
first of all we saw a very similar idea
earlier today Wilson what would you do
that's almost right but it's actually
wrong why cuz in chess it's not just
about attack it's also about defense and
you know of course you can't take it she
can't take care because then it would be
checkmate in one right we're very good
green AJ tech me yeah that's right
hashtag we may take hashtag I like that
so uh huh instead of visit XD 50 black
has it all and quantifies no good
quantity tries no good either we saw
this earlier right what happens down
we're talking about black now it's black
too so what can black through here to
make things not so happy for right
yeah yeah Queens a th2 so this is a
tricky thing that when you're attacking
it's easy to miss your opponent's
resources and the problem now that after
Queen takes h2 what's the worst thing
that can happen when you're attacking
your opponent's king it looks like
you're going to check made him or what's
that that's the worst thing that can
happen the worst the worst thing that
can happen is you get number sign
sexting worst thing that can happen is
what's the essence of an attack almost
every attack involves what piece almost
every successful attack involves the
Queen so when you're attacking and your
opponent finds a way to trade Queens
that's usually a really bad sign for
your attack so that's usually a really
disaster and the problem here would be
after Queen age 29 th-2 because this
night is hanging in the end Black
restores the material balance and whites
attack is ax is finito right so that
would be bad so instead let's take a one
person already got it but let's all take
another minute and try to see what she
didn't then oh let's take a little bit
longer so this is also kind of in a way
this is also a distraction tactic so
we're trying to distract our opponent
from the resources that she has so she
set up this this defensive resource with
Queen takes H to chat simplifying
everything so I think a couple people
have already gotten it and remember when
you're attacking and checkmate is on the
offing material doesn't matter if you
check me your opponent and you're down
two rooks you still win the game right
so that's why or you have to be kind of
come immune to your instinctive desire
to keep as many of your own pieces and
take as many of your opponent's that's
that's what you do when you attack
how many any thoughts here oh you know
you know okay all right so we'll sing
what did you come up with okay so Rick
d7 why didn't you not think it was
correct well but it's different now it's
different because our work is here ready
to mop off all these pieces right so she
can't play Queen takes age too Queen
takes h 2 nite takes h2 but now what
piece are you going to take which one
first of all yeah we take off the Dutch
ribosome now and now when we take off
when they kick off our rock we are now
which piece do we take now somebody
which piece do would you take now would
you take this work on b7 or were you
taking the night off lon why if you take
the dish of movie seven the night is
traps you end up with three pieces for a
rock right so that's why this Queen
takes h2 simplifying tactic does not
work out so well they're right so
basically you found the right idea and
you gave up on it a little bit too soon
all right so that's an important skill
in chess there's two different important
skills in attacking chess one of them is
calculating accurately the other is
having the imagination to find the right
moves so you have the imagination to
find 47 but then you didn't calculate it
accurately right so it's kind of like
you need to really tie both of them in
to become the best calculating player
not calculating the best attacking
player right that makes sense so we're
t-72 the brilliant move because now this
Bishop isn't take the Queen must take
the rock and now all of a sudden when we
play our key move Queen takes h5 there's
no longer any tetrax here with Queen
takes h2 right and so we're just left
with this a glorious finish which you
see
in many tactics books actually the
reason I wrote play like a girl is
because there's not a lot of tactics
books with the positions by female
flyers but this is kind of the exception
you do see this in most tactics books
even old ones so one position that you
kind of see a lot of places this whole
idea of work d7 followed by Queen age
five and again our beautiful to Bishop
checkmate Bishop 87 and the game is over
so very good guys nice work and don't
want to thank you all for coming I'll be
here for a whole nother week